Diana Spencer, Princess of Wales died on the
31st August 1997, aged just 36.
What saddened people more than anything was
the suspicious circumstances around her death
and rumours of murder and betrayal.
This caused mass hysteria, but to this day
we still don't fully understand what happened
that night, on, and off, the streets of Paris.
There have been many theories as to the reason
for her death, many suggest corruption inside
the royal family and MI5, but what actually
happened on that night?
Well here's some of the weirdest facts and
hidden evidence surrounding Diana's death:
The car Diana was in at the time of the crash,
a black Mercedes S280, was the only available
car that night.
But the car had previously been stolen and
only recently found by the rental company
who owned the car.
When it was recovered the only thing missing
from the car was an onboard computer chip.
This chip controlled the car's navigation,
acceleration, steering and braking.
Some believe the original computer chip was
replaced with a doctored one that allowed
remote control of the vehicle, which would
easily allow for a staged crash.
Depending on which report you read, the ambulance
took between 1 hour and 15 minutes and 1 hour
and 40 minutes to get to the hospital, in
the middle of the night.
However the journey should only take 11 minutes,
in rush hour.
Mercedes point blankly refused to inspect
the wreckage, many believe because an experienced
Mercedes engineer would immediately be able
to detect that the car had been tampered with.
Journalists were told outright not to interview
anyone who mentioned "murder".
Although the general consensus amongst the
public eluded to murder, the media never mentioned
it.
Just a few months before her death, Diana
criticised the Royal Family on the BBC's Panorama
programme.
Diana predicted her own death; she had given
her butler and lawyer hand-written notes for
safe keeping.
The note explained that Prince Charles was
planning a car accident to kill her.
The letter reads:
"I am sitting at my desk today longing for
someone to hug me and encourage me to keep
strong and hold my head high.
This particular phase in my life is the most
dangerous.
My husband is planning an accident in my car,
brake failure or some serious head injury
in order to make the path clear for him to
marry Tiggy.
Camilla is nothing more than a decoy so we
are being used by the man in every sense of
the word."
The ambulance driver was ordered by the onboard
doctor to stop and park outside Paris' Natural
History Museum, because Diana was in a critical
condition.
The ambulance driver parked for there for
more than 10 minutes.
However, the hospital entrance was in plain
view of the parked ambulance, but no one rushed
over to help.
It would of only taken the ambulance another
30 seconds to drive to the hospital.
Some believe it was in this ambulance journey
that her injuries were purposely made worse
to ensure her death.
Against all French laws, immediately a team
of embalmers illegally embalmed Diana's body,
whilst it was still warm.
This made any post-mortem examination extremely
difficult to perform.
Therefore doctors were unable to find out
if there had been any tampering with her body
during the ambulance journey.
At the same time of the embalming, the tunnel
was washed down and opened for public use
in just a couple of hours.
The driver, Henri Paul, who died in the crash
was accused of consuming "grossly excessive
quantities of alcohol" and that his reckless
driving whilst under the influence of alcohol
caused the crash.
Although almost every person who talked to
Henri Paul that night has said that he did
not appear intoxicated before the crash.
Blood samples apparently taken from Henri
Paul after the crash, showed that he was hopelessly
drunk.
But was it really his blood?
Interestingly, the blood contained a medicine
called Albendazole which Henri's doctor said
he was never prescribed.
But even more bizarrely, the same batch of
blood samples contained no trace of another
medicine named Acamprostate which Henri Paul
had been prescribed.
The intention of this video is not to point
fingers, I'm only presenting the evidence
as it has been reported, I leave it to you
to form your own opinion.